And now the old scout master.
This is Roger Thor Rupe, assistant scout master in troop 1323, sending a shout out to our troop
and all the troops in the Seneca district of the National Cavalry Council:
Keep up the good work and keep on shouting boys.
Thank you, Roger, for calling with the shout out. This is podcast number 157..
Welcome back to the scout master podcast. This is Clark Green.
Yeah, the voice is a little raggedy. Yeah, we had our big father and son weekend this past weekend
and I make a lot of noise at that weekend apparently.
So hey, let's take a look at the mailbag and see who's been in touch.
Howie Jones said: hi, Clark, like your post about the policy changes,
wondering, in the historical context you brought up, if we might get the authors of the scouting party
to discuss how the BSA has handled change in the past
and what lessons we can learn from for the future.
Thanks so much for being in touch, Howie.
I will have David Scott, the author of the scouting party, doing a presentation with us
for the February scout circle.
And if you don't know what the scout circle is all about, go to scoutcircleorg-
Scoutcircleorg and find out. and that's coming up this Sunday
between 9 and 10 Eastern Standard Time, a live presentation
and you'll be able to ask questions and things,
and we'll be talking about David's book, The Scouting Party.
Let's take a look here.
A friend of mine just sent me your post on the recent membership changes
and I would like to say thank you from the bottom of my heart.
I'm currently an assistant scout, master, merit badge counselor,
Eagle Scout, Wood Badger, former venture explorer,
council camp staff and district volunteer.
I've done a lot in scouting and I also happen to be gay.
In 2009,, at the age of 20, I left scouting because of this policy.
A couple of years later, I was contacted by the chartered organization representative
of a new troupe who knew me from my scouting years
and they were looking for assistant scoutmasters.
I told him my story and his reply was that they did not care.
They would appreciate it if I could come and help them out.
If this policy changes, it resolves the difficult position
any gay scouter like me is in right now.
Like anybody else, I want to serve and give back to scouting,
and that is from Josh and Josh.
Thanks so much for being in touch with us.
Cammy Brandon said thank you for the great info
shared on your Facebook page and website.
I'm an avid fan and I share everything on our troupe Facebook page.
Cammy, it's great to hear from you and thanks for getting in touch.
John Fox wrote to say: hello, Clark.
I'd like to forward, with your permission,
your latest article concerning a possible major change
in BSA policy.
Thank you for your email articles.
Please keep up the good work.
I've had a couple of such requests this week.
Anything that you find on the Scoutmaster blog
or here on the Scoutmaster podcast
is offered freely to assist you in your work in scouting,
and if sharing it with others would help, do that.
absolutely feel free.
The only thing I ask is that you attribute
anything you share to me,
That's it,
But otherwise no permission necessary.
Go ahead and share anything that will help advance
what you're doing in scouting.
David Blomberg wrote in and said:
I've done what you did in the past:
Invited a Scout to come speak to the adults
when we have Weeblows visiting.
I did it last year but I forgot to do it this year.
Oh well, thanks for knocking me in the head
and reminding me,
And, David, I know the feeling.
Thanks for being in touch.
I'm glad I was able to give you a little reminder there.
David Hendrickson is in Cape Gerardo, Missouri,
He said. for the past few days I've been pondering
the words I would use to express my opinion
on the proposed BSA membership policy change
And, as is often the case, I found that somebody else's words-
the words that you had written about the issue-
expressed what I wanted to say.
I've posted it to my Facebook wall.
Having read your comments and responses to other comments,
I believe we are of the same mind
and I'll be visiting your page more often.
If you're ever in Southeast Missouri, give me a shout
And my wife and I will gladly buy you dinner
as gratitude for your excellent insights
into what Scouting should be.
Well, thank you, Rat.
If you're ever in Kenneth Square Pennsylvania,
we'll find a place to have some dinner too.
I could just start driving west
and do a dinner tour, maybe
I don't know
How about it, folks.
Well, I'm sure you've heard in the national news
this past week that the BSA
is considering a change in its membership policy.
This change basically has two parts.
The first would be our national organization
would no longer consider sexual orientation
as a barrier to membership.
The second part of it is that this change
would allow religious, civic or educational organizations
that oversee and deliver Scouting
to determine how to address the issue,
and that the BSA would not under any circumstances
dictate a position to their units, members or parents,
And they would not require any chartered organization
to act in ways inconsistent with that organization's
mission or principles or religious beliefs.
I've written about my take on that
at ScoutmasterCGcom
and there's been a lively discussion that followed.
Not everybody's happy.
If you're a regular reader or listener,
you know that I have declined to make membership policies
a part of the open discussion at ScoutmasterCGcom,
And so this represents a little policy change of my own,
Perhaps not national news,
but I think it's going to be important,
if this policy changes, for us to be able to discuss it,
And I think it's going to be important to do it
in a moderate way.
I mean, naturally this has the potential
to be a divisive issue,
but I think our job as Scouters is to find a way forward
where we can all continue to serve our Scouts,
be loyal to our national organization
and be loyal to the principles
of the worldwide movement of Scouting.
I'm sure there's going to be much more for us
as time goes by,
But podcast 157 is going out
before the absolute change to this policy has been announced,
So I think we'll leave it there for now.
It's time to talk to our friends at Conahoe Creek,
and I've got Bill Fleming on the phone again.
How you doing, Bill?
Doing great,
Clark. hope you're having a good afternoon,
I am,
I am.
Thank you very much.
Listen, we've been talking about this knife sale
that you're doing this month
And it's Boy Scout knives.
There are four different brands involved
And for the month of February at ConahoeCreekcom,
every day a different knife is going on sale.
It will remain on sale for the remainder of the month.
The sale is 10% off of the retail price.
Plus, you can use your coupon code
as a listener to the Scout Master Podcast-
CG113, for an additional 5%.
so it's 15% off of the knives that they're offering.
That's right, Clark,
And we're going to start
with the Remington Boy Scout Camp Knife,
which is actually a replica
of the original, first ever Boy Scout knife.
The Remington I'm looking at right now
on ConahoeCreekcom is a real beauty.
It's heirloom, quality kind of knife.
Tell me a little bit about it.
This particular knife comes with
bull 40 stainless blade,
a cap lifter, slash screwdriver,
a can opener and a leather punch,
And when you pick up this knife
it just feels like quality.
It's a really nice knife
And it will last the scout beyond
their scouting years and into adulthood,
and being something they passed down for many years.
It's a reproduction of the 1924 model
of the Remington
and it comes with a custom display box.
It's a real collector's item, isn't it?
Absolutely,
They won't make these forever.
So, that being said,
I wouldn't be scared to make this
my everyday knife.
Put it to use,
That's what it was made for.
So that's the February knife sale
at ConahoeCreekcom:
C-O-N-O-H-O-Creekcom.
Don't forget the coupon code
for listeners to the Scout Master Podcast:
CG113..
And remember, it's not just knives there.
They've got all kinds of great camping gear.
They'll help you figure out what gear
works for you to meet the conditions
where you go camping
and make sure you get it at a great price.
Thanks so much, Bill.
Thank you, Clark,
and we'll see you at the creek.
In this podcast
in Scout Mastership in 7 Minutes or Less,
we're going to talk a little bit about competition,
And then I've got an email question to answer
And that'll take up the rest of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
Scout Mastership in 7 Minutes
or Less?
So every once in a while
I'll hear somebody talk about competition
in scouting,
And competition is not a bad thing in itself-
not at all-
But I'm going to suggest that the idea
of there always being a clear winner
and a clear loser
is probably not what we want to use
when we talk about competition in scouting.
Boys are naturally competitive.
They like to win
and they hate to lose.
Competing is not bad in itself,
but misapplied,
I think the competition
can be kind of corrosive,
especially with younger boys.
Winning is not always all it's cracked up to be
and losing is definitely not always bad.
We learn from doing things
and giving them a try
and making mistakes sometimes.
Scouting is designed to recognize
not only achievement
but effort.
Competition is a tool.
it's a means to an end,
but it's not an end in itself.
The level of achievement
in scouting
is nowhere near as important
as the effort that gets extended towards that.
What one person can achieve easily
may take somebody else a lot of effort to match.
What we want to do
is encourage effort and confidence
in individuals and in the group.
Baden Powell said this.
boys are especially sensitive
to measures of achievement and failures.
It is the scout master's job
to put these things
into perspective for his boys.
The boy whose inferiority complex
has been born through many failures,
can have his first win or two
made easy for him
so that he is led to intensify his efforts.
If he extends the effort,
no matter how clumsy,
he can earn the badge.
This generally inspires the boy to go on trying
and the sense of inferiority
fades quickly.
You know, we're not all equally talented and gifted.
We can all extend effort
to attain a goal.
When we're young,
we need to learn to deal with dissatisfaction
and disappointment
by assessing the effort we extended,
recognizing how we can improve
and then redoubling the effort.
Scouts need to compete right
And they will compete,
And trying to stop them from competing
is absolutely fruitless.
But what we do, as Baden Powell said,
is put all this into perspective
and show our scouts that it's not really
whether you win or lose,
but how you play the game.
It's not really about just achieving,
but it's about developing resilience
and the ability to encourage yourself,
to look for that effort,
to know that, okay, I'm not as talented
and skilled in every single thing
as everybody else,
but I can put some effort into
becoming a better person.
If we create an environment
that celebrates achievement
and effort equally,
I think we've really done something
and will really be helping our scouts,
Boy Scouts,
Boy Scouts.
Find me a letter,
send it by name
Email. that is, folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Email came in asking me
what I thought about offering
eagle-required maripages
on maripage days.
Now you know what I'm talking about here.
These are these big events
where they may have like a,
they may offer a number of maripages
on a Saturday or something like that.
The person who sent me this email
says that they have a troop rule
that none of their scouts
are allowed to participate in.
The person writing said:
we've had this rule for a long time.
We have a good base of counselors
within the troop that offer
eagle-required maripages,
And I don't want scouts
seeing an easy way out,
And I've seen some things happen
at these maripage days
that I don't consider to be
proper maripage counseling.
So I'm going to agree
with the person who challenged
this rule in your troop
and I'm going to tell you
that you're outside of policy on this one.
A scout gets to choose
his maripage counselor.
So long as a counselor is registered,
there's no reason to prevent him
from using that counselor
And there's certainly no policy
to back up the idea that you can.
A recent change to the maripage application,
the blue card- made it clear
that scoutmasters and
unit leaders are not
pre-qualifying a scout
to take a maripage,
but that they're just making sure
that the scout is going to be working
with a registered counselor.
Now if you have concerns
over the way a particular maripage
is being counseled by a particular counselor,
well then you go
to your district or
council advancement committee
and you share your concerns with them,
because they're the ones who vet
and certify people to be maripage counselors.
There is one way
for a scout to earn a maripage
and that is to go to a counselor
to complete the requirements
to have the counselor certify it, and we're done.
It's really not our place
to question the quality of a scout's work
on a maripage, because that's the
maripage counselor's job.
And I'll repeat myself: if you think
a particular maripage counselor
is not doing a very good job of it,
well go to whoever
certified them and bring that up.
Scouts should be free to choose
the place or the time or the counselor.
Eagle-required maripages
are no different from any other maripage,
other than the fact that they're required
to become an eagle scout. I don't think
they need to be offered with any greater
or lesser rigor than any other maripage.
and I'll add this
while I have the chance:
There are no greater or lesser eagle
scouts. The way a scout becomes an eagle
is they do the
requirements and they pass
a duly constituted border review.
There's no advanced eagle scouts
and there's no lesser eagle scouts,
There's only eagle scouts.
in the same way, There's no scout
that gets an advanced maripage,
There's only maripages.
And once again, if the question
of the suitability of a counselor comes up,
go to the people who vet the counselor.
I think that a rule like this
is kind of inimical to the idea of
the maripage system.
It's definitely outside of policy
and I would just continue
doing it. That's my advice to you,
and if you have a question,
you can get in touch and you'll find out
how to do that in just a moment.
Thanks for listening to this edition of the
Scoutmaster Podcast. Here's how to
keep in touch. Join us over at
scoutmastercgcom. You can register
to receive updates to the blog and the
podcast by email and you can subscribe
to the Scoutmaster Podcast on iTunes
or access it on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio,
And you can get details about
how to do that at stitchercom.
You can experience the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
That's right, we're Scoutmaster Blog
on Facebook, Scoutmaster CG
on Twitter and we
have a Scoutmaster CG circle
for those of you who are on Google Plus.
If all else fails, you can email me,
Clark Green, with your comments, questions
and ideas at
scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet. The
Scoutmaster Blog and the Scoutmaster Podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts
of America, nor are they endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
Hey, it's just me with a microphone
and a raggedy voice,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and maybe have a little bit of fun along the way.
Before we go, let's hear from
our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Powell. Sir Robert,
Good luck to you
and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir? Until next time.
Thank you,
Thank you.